Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 28th,
2013 three days before Halloween.
Everybody Ah,
the little bastards to come and you know they're all going to come walking up to
the door.
Do you know the lovely Nia has canceled Halloween for this year.
She was so fucking mad after last year we went all out and I got the full size
candy bars.
Right.
Cause I wanted to be that house.
The fucking good shit house door.
You got to go up the hill.
I got the full size once,
you know,
like people would actually say anything.
The good people would,
the future banker kids,
they wouldn't say shit.
You know,
they'd sit there with their little fucking Fisher price pocket watch and say
nothing to see here.
And they'd probably try to go back for seconds.
But anyways,
yeah,
I'm behind.
I got to go get up pumpkin.
I gotta make my traditional Pumpkin bread and you can laugh all you want it to
shit.
And if you ever had it,
you'd fucking apologize to me both verbally and in writing.
That's how fucking good my pumpkin bread is.
I'll put it up against any of you fucking ladies and you fucking women out
there.
Huh?
You want to go head to head with my pumpkin bread?
You know what I say?
I say fucking pregnant
now.
No,
I'm joking.
It's,
it's,
it's pretty fucking good though.
Should be no goddamn vegetable oil in it and be fucking moisture February.
Um,
but anyways,
yeah.
Last year that was just a like a bunch of uh,
like high school kids walking up with barely a costume on.
They have that shit eating grin on their face,
you know,
that fucking age.
When kids get into high school and they think they're smarter than adults and
they think adults are morons because uh,
you know,
okay,
well you know,
we're not listening to their fucking music or whatever the hell it is because
they're starting to shave.
They get that fucker look on their face,
which is hilarious.
I don't get mad at it because I did the same thing.
It's really fucking funny when you think about it that you would think that,
I guess because when you look at adults,
we've got wrinkles,
wrinkles on our face.
We got the pot belly.
They forget about the experience,
the life experience that we have.
Like we're not fucking trying to do chin ups here.
Sure.
Young man.
Okay.
We're talking about a little business transaction here with your dumb fucking
fake mustache on.
I know what the fuck you're doing.
You think I didn't do that at your age?
Your little fucking three whiskered cunt.
Get the fuck off my porch.
I see.
That's what I think we should do.
I think we should still hand out the candy because knee has done,
but the whole fucking thing.
Um,
I don't know if you guys listen to my podcast from last year.
There was some fucking guy,
I don't,
I dunno where,
uh,
what his accent was.
Okay.
But he wanted some candy with his kids and this guy was like,
like three years younger than me.
And I just was like,
really?
Really?
And he was just like,
yes.
Like really?
He's like,
yes.
I didn't know what to do.
I've fucking choked in the moment.
I gave him candy.
I should have been like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Okay,
well what is your costume?
Go on as a fucking immigrant.
That's what you are.
That's like me being a redheaded Douche.
Why don't you give me some,
for some of you have fucking baklava whatever.
Fuck you make.
So anyways,
but you know,
I don't want to fuck over the kids.
Kids are adorable and you know,
I,
they're going to get cavities.
I'd like it to come from this house.
They're going to be future,
a little fat fucks.
I'd like to start it right here on my front porch.
So I think she's coming around.
I think she's come around.
We went to the movies last night and we saw a gravity.
We gotta find ourselves a new kind of [inaudible].
MMM.
And that was fucking amazing.
But you know what sucks last fucking like the last five times I've gone to go
see a movie in Imax,
you know,
neo,
he sets it up and I always say,
look,
this is Imax,
right?
This is imax.
Yeah.
See that's the time acts inside me.
There's like imax and then there's imax light where it's the smallest screen.
The only fucking time I've ever gone to a movie and I really saw it in Imax,
is when I saw the Heath Ledger Batman.
And that was one of those deals where I couldn't see the conch head in front of
me and I felt like I was going to fall off the edge of the earth.
All right,
that's Imax.
What I saw last night was not imax.
That was the,
uh,
that was the bud light of imax where it's,
it is a giant screen,
but like to me I,
Emax is all you can see is the screen in front of you.
So fucking annoying.
Those douche bags down there and universal citywalk,
they got like three Imax.
Once they got the real one,
you know,
the Alec Baldwin won and then they got the Billy Baldwin and the fucking Stephen
Baldwin won.
And if you're not careful when you go down there,
they fucking pass you off.
You know,
not saying that it's not still a good experience.
Not saying that those aren't two fine actors,
but it's not an Alec patriated.
It's not him.
All right,
so last,
so I was a little disappointed with that,
but other than that,
that was fucking great.
Sandra Bullock killed it and um,
Jesus Christ.
Um,
and I was just,
just the thought of it.
I think I could actually,
uh,
okay.
I could be at peace floating away from a station in dying that way and solely
just having the oxygen go out is lonely,
is that would seem
just the
fucking,
as long as I wasn't just twirling through the air doing somersaults and there's
a,
there's a side and there's this base and this is [inaudible].
I,
I couldn't fucking handle that if I was just sitting there floating,
looking back at earth and just sort of drifting away.
I think that that would be a pretty fucking cool way to die.
Okay.
What did you just gradually go to sleep?
I don't know.
If you breathe in and only carbon dioxide,
you get like a headache.
I mean that,
that way.
It's such a fucking peaceful way to go.
If you're going to die before your time.
Okay?
Okay.
What do you have fallen off a building fall flat.
Right?
Fucking fucking wind in your ears.
You're going down.
Make him no fucking whatever noise you'd make on the way down.
Fuck that.
Okay.
Getting eaten like I think beyond.
What would you do?
Would you rather get burned to death?
Burned alive.
Oh,
get eaten by a shark.
Amit.
And alive is fucking brutal.
Like if I had to get eaten alive,
I'm going with a big cat,
big cat in Africa.
It's fucking over after seeing the lion tamer there.
Um,
which really,
that's,
that's really just a title.
Nobody teams a fucking lion.
You basically,
you had a good day.
You're,
you're on a good run,
but you know what's going to happen eventually.
You know what I mean?
That's like getting an honorary doctorate from a fucking school.
I have an honorary doctorate from Harvard.
Great.
Well,
you're not smarter than anybody or you don't even as smart as anybody who went
to this school,
you just wrote the mock or Reyna or your fucking head,
your own sitkoff,
you know,
and they knew that all those egg heads,
we're going to be boring as hell when they were giving speeches on graduation
day.
So they brought you in,
you're a fucking clown and they give you a piece of paper.
That's the same thing with lion tamer.
All right?
You're
not taming them.
Okay?
You're trying to break their spirit,
but at the end of the day,
they're a fucking lion and they're the king of the beast.
Okay.
Although some would say that the Bengal tiger could kick the shit out of a lion.
I don't know about kick the shit out of him,
but uh,
I dunno.
But anyways,
just watching that,
uh,
that Lion Tamer in Vegas,
like when,
when that thing grabbed him by the throat,
that dude went limp and like fucking two seconds.
It was like,
when you watch the UFC,
you know,
when someone gets choked out,
you get choked out real fucking quick.
So I don't have,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't want to get mauled,
like I wouldn't want to get attacked by a bear.
They're very sloppy,
you know what I mean?
They're very like rip your face off and uh,
you know,
eat a little buddy.
Yeah.
And then come back later after they took a nap kind of shit.
I like the Lions Tigers.
They just get right to it.
They grab by your fucking throat in two seconds,
sets it,
you're out.
It dead sober.
And then they,
you know,
yeah.
And they have a meal.
I wonder if any of us tastes better than the others.
Like if you ate healthy,
if you're like a,
if you eat like a macrobiotic diet,
if you're like a grass,
like grass fed cattle as opposed to what has sold like me smoking cigars,
drinking booze,
occasionally going to Mcdonald's.
Do I do I taste more like,
you know,
Drake's cakes,
some dried out shit.
I Dunno.
But anyways,
when you look at all those,
and then the worst of all the getting eaten alive other than a fucking Komodo
Dragon,
which would basically bite ya and then slowly follow you around for the next
three days is the poison takes over.
You know,
as you're laying there and the things like two feet away,
you know,
just staring at you.
It's Lizard Tongue flicking at the side of your face but not eaten yet.
You know,
that's fucking horrific.
MMM.
Plus,
you know,
wrap wrap towels.
They just don't,
they just don't have any.
Okay.
There's,
there's no emotion.
The heartless,
they don't give a fuck mammals and even like a lion or something,
they have some sort of understanding what the fuck it is that doing.
Just like,
you know,
reptiles.
I like the terminator.
Okay.
Not even terminate.
It could talk.
I don't know what the fuck they are,
but they freak me out.
I don't lie.
I don't like him.
I really don't.
I respect mammals.
I have,
I,
I don't like reptiles there.
I made that statement and I'm sure I'm going to get some backlash on that and
I'm prepared to go on CNN and defend myself when I go on split screen with some
fucking lizard lover.
But anyways,
so if you're floating through space like I could,
I could die like that.
I definitely could,
as long as it wasn't cold,
as long as that's suit held up and I was just sort of floating,
that would kind of be the most,
uh,
that would be the ultimate premature death.
You're going to die in your 30s,
forties or whatever.
God is still at half my life ahead of me or whatever.
Um,
as long as I wasn't Tumblin if I was just sitting there floating,
looking back at the planet for the last 20 years of my life,
and that's pretty fucking awesome.
You know,
me and lance bass up there just hanging out.
I don't fucking know.
I have no idea.
So anyways,
um,
I am a seven days in,
no,
six days in,
no boobs.
Shut it down.
I'm getting the glow back.
All right.
I've been Jewson.
Um,
although yesterday was a bad day exercise day for me,
I just sat on the couch all fucking day and gave a fuck,
you know,
just watch sports all day and gave a shit.
It was the worst.
I watched that Patriots Dolphin's game with a right heart right out of I ran out
of the gate.
Uh,
my thanks to the officiating crew,
uh,
that,
that worked at game.
I am trying to remember the last time I've watched a game where my team got so
many fucking huge calls to keep the drive going,
that pass interference call on,
uh,
on that defensive back against Gronk.
Koski was criminal criminal,
I believe that gave us,
kept the drive alive.
We've got three points on that one.
And then they had the phantom hands to the face,
flag thrown three,
like three,
four seconds after the play ended.
Travesty.
And then there was the fumble and they said the dolphin slapped it forward or
what?
I mean,
that's one of those borderline,
was he reaching forward or whatever.
But after those other two fucking,
once we get the benefit of the doubt again,
Brady got sacked.
He fumbled the ball and the ball went 10 yards back in the other direction.
We got the ball back and it was first down,
lost 15 yards is still,
somehow it was first down.
And uh,
we were able to come back and beat him.
And I got to say,
um,
the Patriots are,
are overachieving this year.
MMM.
It's really an unreal,
I can't believe the record that,
what are we six and two?
Is that what it is?
We've lost to the jets and we lost to the bangles.
But uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not like I'm a realist.
I know what's going to happen.
We play the Broncos.
I know what's going to happen if we played the Seahawks.
So if he played the colts or even the 40 niners look,
I know Bella check is a fucking genius and that we can somehow,
I don't know what,
but at this point,
you know,
that was what was driving me fucking nuts yesterday is they start the God damn
game and they talk about how the Patriots have injuries at all three levels on
the defense.
We're,
we're missing our best guy,
Vince Wilfork are defensive line.
Best Guy Plus Kelly,
our best linebacker,
Mayo is out for the season.
Our best corner,
a key to leap.
They're all out.
They're all fucking out.
Hernandez went to fucking jail.
Gronk just got back am and Dole is fucking [inaudible] we got,
we got nothing going on,
you know,
so they address that.
And then the end of the game,
I'm watching hall of fame,
fucking players talking about Brady's numbers and how his numbers are down and
go.
This is an atypical,
I mean a top radio with 125 God.
[inaudible] it's like you just fucking said.
How about Tom Brady?
If somehow we're fucking six [inaudible] two with nobody.
Fucking no buddy.
We got nobody.
We got Gronk back,
but we got fucking nobody and was when it Goddamn Games.
And um,
I dunno.
So I am a realist.
So despite the fact that we're six and two,
you know,
I know,
I know.
The Hammer's coming down.
I know it is.
Even if we win the division,
all that,
I mean,
I'm not delusional at all.
And then after I'm dealing with that shit,
I actually call up version to talk about these more on fucking analysts and
fuzzy,
I'm going to start,
it's just sprinkling his fairy dust on the New York giants like every fucking
week.
Right?
They all went one all went to,
and he's just going like,
dude,
you know,
I think we're gonna win next week.
Oh,
in three days,
I think where you went next week.
I went for it,
Eh,
all we'd six.
Right.
And he starts going like,
dude.
Yeah.
And I think we can go on a fucking run here at Blah Blah Blah.
Right.
So now they want two weeks in a row.
Okay.
And I know they're not,
they're nowhere as near as bad as their fucking record,
but first he fucking yesterday did the classic Paul Versey.
Okay.
I remember in,
in when the Patriots play the giants the first time in the Superbowl,
right before the Superbowl starts.
He goes,
dude,
I'm telling you,
I and I,
I think the giants could surprise some people today.
That's what he said.
I think they could surprise some people day.
He wasn't saying they are,
he wasn't putting any money on it.
He just threw it out there,
which is perfect because if they do,
he gets to be like,
don't what I say.
And then if they didn't,
he goes,
well,
I just said,
you know,
I just had a feeling fucking that noncommittal shit.
So now he goes,
the AFC,
NFC fucking east is so fucking pathetic this year.
The giant started Oh and six they're now two and six and there are only two
games out of first.
They could actually win their division.
All right,
which is,
which is classic giants the last like seven years.
It's just like the planets aligned for these guys.
It is their fucking time.
So what is verse he say yesterday?
He goes,
dude,
I'm telling you,
I,
I think they could go on a run.
They get in the plants and then they,
they,
they could,
they could win the Superbowl.
Perfect.
Fucking prediction
didn't say that God didn't put any money down.
He throws it out there.
So I'm guaranteeing you if,
if,
if the giants win the fucking soup bowl,
he's going to go,
dude,
I called it because he threw it out there.
I swear to God,
it's listening to that guy predict shit.
It's like watching a guy play roulette who just comes up with chips and just
fucking dumps some on a bunch of different numbers.
That fucking,
it drives me insane.
And please send this clip to him.
You don't even need to because I'm going to give him shit about it today.
Um,
and I actually liked the giants and that type of thing.
And I think that they could go on a fucking run.
And who knows if they get healthy.
I mean,
who knows.
But I mean,
I don't know.
I don't see them.
Uh,
I dunno the saints,
the fucking Seahawks is a lot of guys to get through.
You know what mean?
But I mean,
if
the way,
the why,
the reason why the NFL is great is everybody does have a fucking shot,
especially if you play in the fucking NFC east.
But,
um,
I don't,
I'm going to give him some shit.
I'm going to tell him right now.
I'm going to call it fucker today.
All right?
And I'm going to say,
listen,
I want you to put money on it right now that the giants are going to win the
fucking super bowl.
All right?
And if you don't put money down on it,
then I don't want to hear a fucking word out of you.
Strive,
you know,
you know what's a classic Paul Versey pick a Zander.
Bogarts
uh,
I was watching that shit.
You know,
just watching the guy.
I hear it a little hyper bottom.
I read a little bit about them and then I watched like two at bats and I'm
watching this 21 year old kid work in the count in the fucking world series and
a,
I'm like,
this is a verse he pick right here.
He would jump on the bandwagon.
Dan,
I'll tell you,
I think this kid get doe shopped it.
Oh,
is he going to be pissed at me?
I'm just fucking with you Paul.
But for the love of God,
just say some Shit's going to happen.
It puts some fucking money on it.
Stop with the fucking,
uh,
I'll tell you,
you know,
I think it could rain this week.
Um,
alright.
Plowing ahead here.
A lot of sports is fucking week as always.
I feel really bad because I've been neglecting my Bruins.
I know we lost to the devils and I know we beat,
think we beat San Jose crazy and a last second shot.
I've just been wrapped up watching baseball and uh,
I got to tell you,
dude,
I did not miss it.
Watching playoff baseball when your team is in,
it will take fucking 30 years off your life per game.
Okay.
And um,
and I know that's not a unique experience.
I know tigers fans have gone through it and I know cardinals fans have gone
through.
It's certainly with us being to two games apiece and,
um,
I gotta tell you it's been exciting,
but I fucking hate baseball.
I can't handle watching the shit.
I hate that there's no fucking clock.
It just,
I hate that you just can't fucking win a game easily.
You can't just be up a bunch of fucking runs and everything's good.
You can't just be up four to one and it's all good.
You know,
it's some point between the sixth and the eighth inning.
The other team is some arguer walks the front of the first guy on base and then
it's just going to be this fucking nightmare and then they're going to take the
guy out.
Some other fucking stiff is going to come in and it's just,
I have Tourette's when I watch it,
I have to walk away.
I have to go in the other room.
I have to put the thing on mute because I'm convinced Tim McCarver not hates the
red sox and the Yankees.
I learned that he hates the Yankees through Versie and uh,
you know,
he's a former cardinal.
I just think he just fucking,
and I really trying to listen objectively going is this guy criticizing the
cardinals the way he's criticizing it's slash predicting possible bad shit for
the red sox.
Fucking guy drives me up the Goddamn wall.
Um,
and he,
he says positive shit about Ortiz and positive shit about Zander bogarts.
And other than that,
it's just gloom and doom with that guy.
Drives me up the fucking wall,
but,
um,
I have no idea who's going to win this series.
And a,
it's been a great series so far in two of the most bizarre endings to games,
games out three and four and that,
uh,
that obstruction thing,
I'm not going to be a bitch and complain about it.
Um,
I don't know what the rule is.
Like most baseball fans,
the first time I saw the definition of it was that night.
And uh,
I don't fuck it though.
I mean I think it's more positive way of looking at is probably we shouldn't
have thrown the ball down the third base slash we probably should have caught
the ball and uh,
I don't,
I don't know how you call obstruction when you miss the first,
the first half of the collision.
That wouldn't be my only part of it,
but it seemed like everybody,
including our own managers said they got it right.
So,
uh,
so they got it right.
The fuck you going to do.
Um,
whatever.
It's tied up to anybody's fucking gay man.
I hope we're going to win.
Obviously I'm what the Red Sox to win.
But I really want us to win because I can tell how much Versie wants us not to
win.
How much he fucking hates the red sox in their fucking beards and their anti
anti Yankee dress code.
It's driving him like the level that he gives a fuck makes me laugh because it
reminds me of the ridiculousness of why do I care?
It's like,
look,
especially at first he was like,
what the fuck,
Dude,
you got 27 championships.
If we win this one,
it's our eighth.
What is the problem?
But he for some reason,
fucking hates the Red Sox,
you know,
for the most part,
other than oh four and the last fucking nine years we've done nothing but
wonderful things for the Yankees.
And you know,
you'd think if Chicago could find it into the,
in their hearts to,
to thank us.
You know,
you'd think that a Yankee fan like virgin could say something nice,
you know,
but I don't think he has it in him.
Um,
I'm just fucking with them.
All right,
let's,
let's do a little advertising here for this week.
Uh,
what did we get here?
What do we got?
The Usual,
oh,
this,
this is,
this is the one that's been blowing up and I've been getting nothing but
positive reviews.
Everybody are you a man?
That probably means you got to shave,
right?
Unless you got that fucking kid disease.
Well,
you never get any whiskers cause your parents smoked too much weed or whatever
the fuck.
However you get that disease.
Is that a technical disease?
I don't know what it is.
Um,
dollar shave club,
everybody,
there's so many things in the world that irritate me.
Um,
people who had no idea what the obstruction rule was and then watched it on ESPN
and then start breaking it down like they went to law school.
That irritates me.
Uh,
what else irritates me?
I don't fucking know.
Okay.
The fact that I've been eating so well and doing great and then I went to the
movies last night,
got a kit Kat and peanut fucking m and m's like that wasn't enough sugar.
Daddy irritates me out a bunch of stuff.
Irritates me anyways,
when so many things can irritate you.
Why would you add razors to that list?
It's time to stop milking your razor blades.
Everybody I know with brand name razors,
you used to paying outrageous prices and exhausting those raises and razors
until they start looking like a rusty soda cans.
Well,
guess what?
It's time to move on.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing quality blades right to your God damn door
for just a couple of bucks a month so you never have to think about it again.
They sent a pack every month so you can change your blade every week.
I love these guys and your face is going to love them too.
They also have a new product called a one white
one wipe Charlies everybody.
What is it?
It's a buttwipe for men and it's classy.
You wipe your ass with your pinkie hanging out.
Um,
check out,
check out the video and a sign up for your razors today.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash burr.
That's dollar shave club.com forward slash bar or go to [inaudible] dot com and
click on the dollar shave club banner.
Alrighty,
they,
you'd go Hulu plus everyone.
You've probably tried hulu.com well,
guess what?
Now it's time to try and Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus lets you watch thousands of hit TV shows and a selection of a claim.
Movies on your television or the aunt or you can use the on you go with the uh,
the smart phone or tablet.
What the hell?
Let's just say they or on the goal with your smartphone or tablet.
I was doing so well and it all streams in HD for the best viewing experience
possible with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite current TV shows like Saturday night live
community and family guy.
You could also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals like the
awesome starring SNL Seth Meyers and soon to be late night talk show hosts Seth
Meyers and Moon Boys' starring Chris O'Dowd from bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection of a claim films for only seven 99 a
month.
You can stream as many TV shows and movies as you want,
wherever you want.
You can't beat that deal right now.
You can try Hulu plus for free for two weeks.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill that's a special offer from my listeners.
Everybody,
make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so you can get the extended free trial and
that they know that we sent you.
Go to Hulu plus.com/bill now or click on the Hulu plus banner on the podcast
page at [inaudible] dot com there you go.
Anybody watched fast and loud this week?
I taped a bunch of episodes and a,
I have a new favorite car.
I've always been a Ford guy and I'm the Dude Casey on the show,
the cars,
which I think is so fucking bad ass.
I was never really into the bodywork at first.
I was into watching them,
you know,
do the suspensions and dropping motors in,
in that type of thing.
But over the,
uh,
you know,
years of watching the shit on youtube and watching people redoing cars and
stuff,
I'm really starting to get into the,
you know,
no one had a paint the car just,
and it looked so fucking easy,
but I watched Richard do it one week and he sucked at it.
So I really see that there's an art to it.
But anyways,
that Dude Casey on the show had this,
uh,
55 Ford custom line and a,
I think it was what?
Custom line or custom liner?
I'd never heard of it.
I was always sweat in the fucking bell airs thinking that Chevy was doing it
right.
And uh,
let me look this up here.
Yeah,
a custom line.
And they redid that one and they painted it fucking all white.
They took the chrome off of it.
That car was the shit.
And then they ended up selling it to a mark Cuban of the Dallas Mavericks.
And uh,
I swear to God,
if you ever get sick of that car,
I'd buy it.
I buy it off of,
I don't know if I pay what the fuck he paid for it.
I don't have that kind of money,
but Jesus such a bad ass fucking car.
So anyways,
um,
I'm in town after,
you know,
I've been on the road this hope basically this entire year and a,
I got a two week break here and I've been really enjoying myself just hanging
around the house finally.
Um,
I got back into playing drums a little bit.
I'm doing that Mike Johnston 10 days to faster hands workout.
I highly recommend it.
I'm six days in as of today,
I'm finally able to stick with it just because,
you know,
when I travel I kind of barnstorm around where it's like a different city every
night and it's really hard.
You know,
you bring a practice pad and your drum sticks and trying to find a table high
enough,
it's a big pain in the ass.
So I'm making sure that I'm doing it this time.
I'm sticking with it.
And um,
anyways,
I'm getting back into all my,
all my hobbies.
Uh,
believe it or not this week,
I'm actually going to try to make homemade Ravioli.
Okay.
I Dunno.
I'm all over the fucking map.
Nia said that to me the other day.
She goes,
you're all over the map.
You have a d d you can't fault.
You play drums,
you play guitar,
you make Pumpkin bread.
You know,
you can fix cars a little bit.
The outskirts basically.
I can't really fix cars.
I can do little bullshit on it.
I could have fucked up my seat belt.
I gotta put that in.
That's a couple of bolts can handle that shit.
Whatever.
You ride motorcycles a little bit.
You're all over the fucking map.
And I was like,
wait a minute.
But I stuck with stand up comedy.
I've been doing that almost 22 years straight.
And she goes,
yeah,
well,
you know.
Yeah.
Well you know,
that's the fucking thing I do.
Everything else is the other shit I do.
Is that right?
Cleo liquor over there,
she got a two beds stacked up on each other like a fucking double cheeseburger.
Never seen anything sleep more.
And it's life and that dog,
oh,
by the way,
I'm doing a,
I'm doing a benefit this Sunday,
Sunday,
I'm doing a benefit,
um,
for a,
for pit bulls rescue pit bulls in,
it's going to be down at Largo theater this Sunday.
That would be November,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
Second or third November 3rd,
I'm going to be down there,
um,
with a bunch of other Comedians,
a bunch of dog lovers.
Who the hell else is on it?
I can't remember me,
Whitney Cummings,
couple of other people.
And uh,
I did this benefit last year and it's a great cause and what's even it's even
better is they bring a bunch of pit bulls down there and uh,
it's really is my favorite fucking dog.
And she's just the best.
They get the best heads.
They're fucking jacked.
You know,
you should see my dogs,
my dog's legs.
It's ridiculous.
Her back legs when she goes to stretch,
I'm telling,
I've said this before,
you remember that road runner,
um,
episode.
We'll wildly,
coyote took that shit to make him run really fast and he's running and he had,
the flames were that he took,
it was like roids for his thighs.
That's what a fucking legs look like.
Um,
in every morning she wakes up and I squeezed him like Shannon.
all right.
Hey,
last week I talked about the Greenpeace 30 and now they got arrested for piracy
and just like,
was there any sort of thought behind,
you know,
but you're boarding a goddamn Russian,
I don't know,
drilling platform me.
What the fuck did you think was gonna Happen?
So they got arrested for piracy and I'm going to really follow this.
Uh,
um,
I'm really going to follow this story to see what happens.
It's just insane.
Like right now they are,
first of all,
it got dropped down.
Let's see here.
Green Greenpeace,
Arctic Arctic thirties plight highlights the inhumanity of Russian jails.
All right,
that's a different one.
Um,
it's now a month now since the 30 green peace activists arrested for attempting
to board the,
I'm not even gonna try to say it.
Why not?
I'll give you a laugh.
Prior Zam Olana,
Yammer,
fucking oil platform were transferred from police lockups to remand prisons in
Murmansk,
the Merman.
It's region in the Arctic circle.
That really scared the shit out of me.
Like I literally thought that they were on just,
they built these jails on the ice,
but it's sort of the one of the most northwest,
I think it's the most northwest city in Russia,
basically,
uh,
butts up against like Finland,
Sweden,
Norway,
like the top of those countries.
So they're kind of all the way up there in these goddamned jails.
And um,
where the hell is it here?
They actually were able to,
uh,
they reduced the charges so they're now Russia drops,
piracy charges,
cuts,
maximum jail term and half acts of his face up to seven years in prison if
convicted.
Basically they,
they,
I think they knocked it down to a,
I don't know,
almost like hooligan behavior says Russia on Wednesday dropped a piracy charges
against 30 people involved in a Greenpeace pro.
No,
sorry about that.
The battery's cut out on me.
I'm speaking of green peace.
So it was trying to make sure I used up all my other batteries before I fucking
throw him out cause I don't know where the fuck to recycle them.
Um,
where the hell was I?
I'll just start it over again.
They dropped a piracy charges but Blahblahblahblahblah they face up to seven
years down from 15 years.
The charges against the activists who protested the platform,
um,
the last months have been changed from piracy to hooliganism.
The Federal Investigative Committee said,
and there's a whole green peace thing if you guys want to get involved and try
to help to get these knuckleheads out of jail.
Uh,
I dunno,
like protesting,
this is a really sad truth.
Protesting is difficult enough in your own country,
even if you have a democracy,
because you know the cops are gonna show up,
you know what the deal is.
And as much as you tell everybody,
just remain peaceful and then they won't club is down.
Somebody eventually ends up throwing a rock or doing something or some
conspiracy theorists say that,
that the government hires somebody to go in with the protesters and throw
something.
So then the cops can then beat him down and tear gas.
And I don't know if that's fucking true,
but I'd love to think it is.
Um,
it's hard enough to fucking do it in your own country.
I got to give it up the fucking balls.
Those people had to try and do that.
Um,
and just the situation that they're in,
it reminds me of that documentary I saw on that.
Yeah.
The Ganja Queen.
Did you guys ever see that was basically this lady that went to a Bali and I'm,
according to her,
she loaded a boogie board with a Boogie,
you know,
she checked that and that was you're carrying on.
And then when she got off the,
uh,
the plane,
the Bali state fucking troopers came over and said,
hey,
is that your boogie board?
Fucking Satchel?
And she goes,
yeah,
it is.
And then they opened it up and there was all this Wieden,
there was all these wee man and they don't in Indonesia,
they don't fuck around.
When it comes to a drugs,
they have a zero tolerance,
zero tolerance for it.
And if you get busted with the shit,
I think they put you to death is what they usually do.
And they say that,
I just did Tom Rhodes podcast and we will,
we kind of a towards started to talk about this and they basically,
uh,
he's,
he's been to Bali.
And I was like,
dude,
don't you get scared?
And you just sort of laughed.
He goes,
no,
I just don't bring any drugs into the country.
And I'm just kind of like,
well,
what if just something happens?
What if somebody next to you has,
I'm a,
just shoves him in your pocket.
I know that's written a ridiculous fear,
but like,
you know what I mean?
Look,
I'll go to another country and I,
and the countries that if you kill somebody,
it's punishable by death.
And I can,
I can live within that because I just can be like,
well,
you know,
I'm not going to kill anybody.
I think it's because over here,
if you get busted with weed and a lot of states,
now it's legal and then,
um,
they didn't,
if you get busted,
it's like no big deal.
Unless of course you have a bunch of it and you get,
you get busted for trafficking,
that's a whole other deal.
But I mean,
it's not like somebody can just drop a bunch of kilos of weed on you,
plant that on,
you,
stick them in your fucking backpack,
you're going to know they're there.
But just the fact that you have one God damn join on you.
Yeah.
Like dude,
I would walk into that country
naked.
I come in with a fucking speedo.
I get a colonic the week before I would juice for a fucking month.
Okay.
And,
uh,
I would have a cattle prod and keep all other passengers away from me and I
would walk into,
they're wearing a goddamn thong.
And that's the only way I even then I would be scared.
Okay.
Punishable by fucking death.
Jesus Christ.
So anyways,
if you,
if you want to watch something really disturbing,
um,
watch this gun.
Ganja Queen was what she was called in the papers over there and they opened up
or Boogie board a Satchel or whatever the fuck you call it,
carry on case and there was a bunch of weed in there and uh,
she,
they,
they were like,
we're going to put you to death in the Australian,
whatever the fucking syndicate,
whatever you call it.
The embassy tried to get this woman out of it and uh,
just watched that documentary,
this,
I mean obviously the Greenpeace 30,
then I got to get put to death,
but I'm sitting here scrolling across the maps here looking at this shit where
Bali is over an inch and there's Murmansk.
There it is right there.
Jesus Christ.
I just fuck that.
How the fuck is anybody going to help you?
Oh my God.
That's why I always do that Amnesty International because that is a fucking fear
of mine just being thrown in a Goddamn jail.
Do you ever watch,
you remember that show arrested abroad?
Did you ever see that thing?
I watched that with Neil one time and Neil loves traveling.
She goes that that made me never want to fucking go anywhere again in my life.
But it's just,
what was one of those things?
It was always like these fucking people were trying to smuggle drugs out of the
country.
I mean,
I'm trying to think of something that takes more balls than that.
Okay.
I'm sure that you guys can come up with something,
but you know,
just being in a country where if you get caught,
you're going to go into their God damn.
Okay.
Gulag.
And you're not going to be able to speak the language.
You talk about a man without a fucking country and you're going to have to go in
there.
I mean,
John Club van Damme is,
he's gaze at the height of his powers is getting fucking ass rate in that
situation.
That's just,
you're done.
You're fucking finished.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
I get not walking in a cubicle.
They wanted to make you fucking money.
But I,
there's a,
there's gotta be some other talent that God gave you will,
you can make money that doesn't evolve.
Shoving a Kia coke up your fucking ass trying to get out of Columbia.
There's gotta be another way to do it.
Right,
right.
And you're fucking moped to the airport on unpaved roads.
This distressed after there has to be a better way.
It's gotta be a better way to do it.
Um,
anyways,
let's fucking move on here.
Let's,
let's,
are we far enough into the podcast here and now that the thing cut out?
I've got to do the math here and was at 35.
Uh,
Jesus,
I don't fucking know.
Let's,
uh,
let's read a,
um,
okay.
I think I went through everything that I wanted to talk about,
didn't I?
Oh yeah.
I'm a little out of it here.
I haven't eaten yet today because last night I ate late,
late at night,
ate it like a,
like one in the morning,
I think is when I finally stopped eating.
Um,
came home,
I had one of those fucking name Antipasto plates and,
uh,
like fucking one in the morning.
And I adhere by that rule that you go 12 hours after your last meal.
Like if eda o'clock at night,
eat the next day,
eight in the morning.
I stayed up till one in the morning,
so I'm not eating until one in the afternoon.
All right?
That's how you become a top of shit,
right?
You go to bed at one,
you wake up,
it's seven 30 in the morning.
You have to go to work and then eat a bacon,
egg and cheese or a fucking doughnut.
And so it's fucking over.
So,
uh,
that's it.
I tell you,
I got down to like fucking a buck 70.
I told you I was going to get into a
sitting down.
No showed on shape.
That's what I want to get back to.
Just one more fucking time in my life.
You know,
they always making these movies,
you know,
they're gonna do it one more time.
They got one coming out that I'm going to go see that.
That one with Deniro,
uh,
Michael Douglas and fucking,
Morgan Freeman.
Alan Arkin.
Oh,
I think he's in that too.
I don't know if they're all in that,
but like,
I'm going to go see,
you know,
they're doing it one more time.
Right.
That's what the fuck I'm doing with my stomach.
And it's,
I'm having a hell of a time because if you just stop eating,
you end up losing muscle.
All of a sudden it looked down at my right,
the arms of a seventh grader,
and I still had my little fucking beer belly,
you know,
looking like a God damn turtle.
Right?
So I got to do something.
I gotta,
I gotta fucking eat more meat and fucking do a mark.
I don't know what I got to do.
Probably have to get a personal trainer.
I don't want to do that.
If somebody holding my ankles and I'm doing sit ups,
I can't fucking do that shit.
Oh,
speaking of Michael Douglas,
you know,
I finally sat down and I watch behind the candelabra,
I am.
Um,
I,
I'm too homophobic.
I was too homophobic to watch it.
And,
uh,
you know,
this is the thing about being home,
being homophobic.
There's all different levels of it.
Like that word,
oh,
he's homophobic.
And then he'd get it.
Like,
you think gays are going to hell and they shouldn't be married and what they're
doing is unnatural.
And I'm not homophobic like that.
Uh,
I think,
you know,
being gay is just how you're naturally wired,
so it's completely natural and go out and fucking have at it,
you know,
fuck as many as you can.
Don't you think?
Don't give a fuck,
get married,
have a hell of a fucking time,
you know,
God bless you.
But,
uh,
I,
I get like a,
I don't know what it is in movies when there's guys kissing each other and
caressing each other.
I egg makes me fucking uncomfortable.
And then there was something about watching Michael Douglas and Matt Damon
playing footsie with each other.
Like that fucking,
I didn't want to see him in a hot tub together.
I,
I couldn't fucking watch it,
comfortable talking about it,
but whatever,
I'm being honest.
So anyways,
that was on the road or something.
I don't know where the fuck I was at.
I was back in Boston and it came on and I watched the second half of it and I
gotta tell you something that was,
it was absolutely fucking phenomenal.
Was fucking hilarious.
I'm going to have neon here at some point and do her Michael Douglas impression
going Scad,
Scad.
I can't,
I can't do it as well as she can.
Um,
they will.
They work.
Michael Douglas and Matt Damon killed it and that fucking movie.
And uh,
and I was actually rooting for Matt Damon's character.
I felt bad for him.
It's like,
dude,
you got to get out of this relationship.
You fucking up your face.
You got to get off the drugs.
You know,
he's bringing in some younger guy,
unique.
The writing's on the wall.
You gotta get Outta here,
man.
Go take some night classes,
you know,
do something else to fuck he doing with this old man.
Lose sparkly fucking coach and his damn to pay kick G.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
He's using Yah,
I got into it like that.
That's how well it was done.
Um,
highly recommend that two thumbs up behind the candelabra.
Oh,
fucking homophobe Billy.
He liked it.
I'm not 100% homophobe.
Well,
20% homophobe
is that a standard offensive to say?
Homophobe am I suppose to say homophobic?
There's something about abbreviating shit that makes people annoyed.
Like you're not supposed to say trainee anymore.
And you know what's funny?
I don't even know if that's short for transvestite or transsexual.
I don't understand why that's bad.
Okay.
That's like if you name's Mike and some of the gay Mikey
is that bad?
You know,
that's really offensive.
My name is Michael.
Thank you very much.
Transvestite.
What do you say,
Dick and address.
Why are you doing there buddy?
Sweet at,
you know,
you can't fucking say that evidently.
Even despite if in your heart you don't think there's anything wrong,
I don't give a fuck if that's what you want to do.
God bless you.
You know,
Put on some fucking heels,
walked down the street and let people know what you're doing.
Um,
I don't give a shit.
I really don't.
Just fucking don't play your music too loud.
Don't trick or treat past a certain age.
And uh,
I don't know what else if you're drunk,
I don't mind if you talk to me when you're drunk.
Just,
you know,
keep your distance.
Does anything worse than what somebody said.
I had somebody over the weekend,
I was down at the comedy store and just somebody was fucking wasted and they
just,
you know,
somebody is wasted due and they just come up to you.
You're in the middle of a conversation,
is it,
can bard,
they become like,
you know,
like toddlers don't give a fuck.
They,
they have no concept of two people talking.
They'll just barge in on the conversation and they'll,
they'll just,
I just think he used to do a bit on this.
I don't even know if I ever put it on a special ice to talk about how they look
like they were like drunks and they would just start in the middle of the
conversation,
middle of a story,
let you try and figure it out.
Um,
I don't even want to talk to him about let,
let's,
let's read it.
Let's read some of this shit here.
Um,
all right.
Is 29 two old.
Hey,
they Billy bandwagon.
For those of you who don't follow me on Twitter,
I uh,
been going by bill bandwagon watching the red sox and uh,
I got to tell you right now,
I am not built bandwagon anymore after fucking aging 30 years watching all of
these goddamn games,
I am back to die hard.
I'm not die hard.
Maybe I am.
Maybe I'll,
maybe I'll come back to watching a baseball.
We'll see the jury is out,
but uh,
Bill Bandwagon left after we lost two games in a row and there was the
obstruction call he took off and die hard bill fucking hung around.
All right.
Anyways,
first he says,
I just want to say love the podcast and your comedy special,
so thank you very much.
Uh,
he goes,
my question,
do you think 29 is too old to start doing standup?
Um,
I have a decent fulltime job as a paralegal and consider myself lucky to be
gainfully employed.
However,
life in an office is miserable and it gets worse.
The years pylon.
I'm not quitting anytime soon.
But if thought about starting to try open mikes to see if I'm any good and
maybe,
and maybe what maybe helped me be a little more outgoing,
what do you think?
Is it still possible when you damn near third 30.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself dude.
Apps of fucking lutely absolutely.
And this is the thing.
Yeah,
don't quit your day job.
That's what I did.
I,
I had a day job and I was like,
let me try this stand up thing.
And I started doing it and I immediately loved it and I just kept working on it
and working on it,
working on it.
But I didn't leave my day job until,
um,
I actually kept my day job when I could have left it.
I was making enough money where I could live,
but I kept my day job because I knew I was moving down in New York and I wanted
to save up some money so I could,
um,
because I knew that I,
you know,
I wasn't going to show up in New York and they all great.
This fucking guy we don't know is here.
Let's give him a bunch of stage time.
I knew I was going to have to struggle,
so I would absolutely 100%.
If you're thinking about trying it,
definitely try.
Even if you just do it one time you did it.
You did it.
I went skydiving one time.
I have to tell you guys that story.
If I did a static line jump in Pepperell Massachusetts back in the day and uh,
I almost had a problem.
They said,
sit in the door.
It sit in the door,
get out,
go.
So you sit in the door,
they opened the door to the plane,
you sit in the door.
And then when I say get out,
you put your feet,
you put one foot,
your left foot on,
this almost looks like an engine mount that's above one of the wheels of this
fucking plane.
Okay.
And then you're hanging on to the support for the wing that is above the fucking
plane.
You're basically like a God damn wing Walker.
And then I'd be basically,
if you'll,
if you leaned up against the bar,
If you put your body in a 45 degree angle and you leaned up against the bar in
the upright push up position and then you went down like you were coming down to
the floor,
that's basically the position you're in.
Like you're down to the floor,
except it's the support to the wing.
And then you have one foot on the engine,
what it looks like an engine mount,
and then you have another foot pointed straight out behind you.
Because what you're going to do,
it says skin,
you know,
sit in the door,
get out and go.
When he slaps your shoulder,
you let go of the fuck plane,
which makes no fucking sense.
And then you bring that other leg up parallel to where your other one was
setting out and then you arc.
All right.
And what I did was a static line jumps so I don't have to pull the shoot,
but I don't have anybody with me to static line jump.
And as you let go,
it pulls your shoot and you and you go arc 1002 1003 1000 look,
if nothing look reached,
pull.
I still remember that shit like it was yesterday.
Okay.
Two,
1003 1000 and it's look,
you turn to see your parachute to see if it's opened,
if it's open property properly,
what it look,
if nothing,
look,
you look down to where your reserve is.
Cause if he,
if he don't look where it is for some reason you might not be able to grab it.
So look,
if nothing,
look,
reach,
pull.
And then you pull your reserve chute and hopefully that thing fucking opens.
Are you going to bounce?
So
okay,
he said he was going to sit in the door and I was like,
what?
He's going sit in the door.
I thought he said,
close the door.
He's going to sit in then I file.
Okay,
so sit there though.
So I sit in the door and then he goes,
get out.
I got out and then he said go.
And when I let go,
I didn't arc.
I tried to grab for something and I started doing front flips as my shoot was
coming out and I felt it going by the inside of my right leg.
I felt this something touch my right thigh and I was going,
Oh my God,
I'm going to pee.
I'm going to get wound up in this fucking thing.
And uh,
I don't know who packed that shoot,
but thank God it fucking came out.
And then you had like a little transistor radio or some shit on your shoulder
and then they just talked you down,
you know?
Right.
Toggle left toggle.
You had to pull it all the way down to your knee.
And I remember there was this fat chick in the class and she couldn't get it
around her ass and she ended up landing across the street and a pile of loom and
she dislocated her knee.
Uh,
fortunately that did not happen for me and it was a,
it was pretty awesome.
But I did it that one time.
Never needed to do it again.
And,
uh,
I have the story,
I have the experience.
So maybe stand up.
We'll just be that for you.
Um,
or you could have the experience that I had were the first time I walked to the
microphone,
I felt like I was like an out of body experience.
Like I was watching myself do it.
And um,
okay.
It was a,
I found my calling in life,
which is probably one of the most exciting things other than finding the person
you're supposed to be within life.
So I got to tell you this dude,
if you're in your office every day and it,
it is a miserable thing,
that could mean that you're not,
you don't have the right job or you need some sort of outlet.
Maybe you're working too hard and maybe just going out and doing this one night
and kind of remembering to try that going out and try new things is a fun thing
to do.
Yeah.
You don't have to just be 100% about your career.
That's all.
I think that's the thing a lot of fucking adults forget to do after a while.
And you have like that thing.
Once you get your life down,
you know,
I get up at this hour,
I drive down this street and I go to work.
I do the same thing every day.
I'm comfortable.
I know everybody.
There's no new challenges and then no one's gonna make fun of me like they did
on the playground and punched me in the face for having freckles.
Right.
You can really get caught in that.
And then you get in a Rut.
So I don't know if you just in a Rut with work or whatever,
but I would definitely recommend trying,
uh,
going out and try and stand up.
Believe me,
dude,
it's a,
I'm having more fun with it than I ever had an up 22 years in and I've,
I never feel like,
wow,
I've had some struggles,
you know,
but you do with anything.
But when I'm on stage doing it,
I never feel like,
mmm,
I don't feel like how you feel in the office,
but I'm not going to lie to you before I started selling tickets,
you would when you would.
It's just a fucking awful show and there was no security and everything,
but you know,
anything worth having,
you know,
fish was fucking easy.
Everybody would do it.
So anyways,
I'm getting too long winded here.
Go out and try it.
All right,
next one.
A dear bill.
You ruined the hobbit.
Um,
he said I'm a big fan of the podcast and your comedy.
Unfortunately,
I made the mistake of looking up your comedy on Youtube and came across the clip
where you took a shit on Lord of the rings.
You know what's funny?
I don't even remember doing half of this shit.
I,
you said it was the scene where the Gandalf stumbles,
summons shadow facts,
the Lord of all horses.
Oh Jesus.
And you pointed out how ridiculous that was.
Oh,
I remember that.
I am the Lord of all horses just so fucking over the top.
He goes,
I don't consider myself to be a big nerd,
but I do love Star Wars,
Lord of the rings and all that nerd stuff.
I like all of that shit.
I watched the Hobbit for the first time yesterday and every time they said
something ridiculous,
I pictured your ginger mug going,
oh Jeez.
That was literally laughing every 30 seconds.
Well,
there you go.
Then I turned lord of the rings into a comedy for you.
Um,
you know,
I saw a clip of one of those things with a guy just looks like,
and he has elf ears and he talks to the,
to the,
I am assuming a wizard,
you know,
why don't wizards ever get a haircut?
You know,
why don't they ever have a take,
you know,
take it shave.
Why don't you know why white?
Why can't you be a clean cut wizard?
Are you so busy moving fucking mountains,
you know,
somebody gets,
get them a little of those little toiletry bags,
the straight razor.
Um,
I was watching one of those things in,
okay,
I remember where the fuck I was at.
So I got on a plane.
It was I watching TV.
It's all running together at this point.
My age days fly by so quick,
he can't even remember.
Did I dream that or did my neighbors say it?
I can't even fucking remember.
But I was watching one of those Elf movies and,
uh,
the fucking lead dude with the Karl Malden knows in the Spock ears.
He,
he found,
he found a ring.
Now for some reason I thought the ring,
the Lord of the rings,
like if you had the rings,
I thought the rings will like,
you know,
those magic rings that hacky magicians pull apart.
I thought that they were that big.
It looked like he found a wedding ring.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
so he said he was laughing every 30 seconds.
I'm am I,
he said,
I hope you're happy that my enjoyment of the hobbit was a casualty on your war
on nerds.
I don't have a war on nerds.
I just call them out on this shit.
How arrogant is that?
I just try to keep them off the list.
I do think that they should teach nerds out of fight rather than trying to stop
bullying because you're not going to end bullying.
You know,
it's like I started watching the,
uh,
the ultimate fighter where they have these,
the women fighters now and I'm telling what I watched when I watched those women
fight.
I get like,
like site for going.
Like I hope some pervert tries to grab her ass.
Like I hope a rapist.
Like I would never wish that on any of them.
But for the love of God,
the next time a rapist tries to rape a woman,
a women,
a woman,
like if she has the fucking skills that the women on the,
on the ultimate fighter,
I mean,
it's just going to be,
it's just going to be a great day for,
for humanity.
Um,
you got to see that show,
dude,
these,
these women,
like for the most part,
they,
they spar with men because I don't think there's enough women in the sport or
whatever.
So these guys are kind of half ass in it and the women are going like,
it's,
you know,
it's okay to hit me in the face.
I'm just sitting there like watching the guy fighter still pulling his punches
because it just goes against everything that you were taught and everything that
is just right in the world to ball your fists up and actually swing in,
in punch a woman is just like,
I just don't think Christmas would ever be the same after that.
Like it just,
it would just be something
you just,
you just would lose something.
Um,
but anyways,
I mean they,
like I can tell you without a doubt,
every woman on that show would beat the living shit out of me.
I wouldn't have a prayer.
There's nothing you can do once the that mixed martial arts,
you know,
if a woman look like a woman boxer,
you have a chance you could outwear and you can just fucking just shoot her legs
and fucking put her on her back and just smother her with a pillow from the
couch.
Right?
You got a shot.
But that UFC shit,
you take him to the ground and then what?
Then they're going to fucking put you in an arm bar.
They're going to choke you out.
It's going to be over.
So of course me being a guy,
being a fucking pig,
I of course got to look at them in a sexual way and I'm like going like,
all right,
how do you rock that girl's world in the fucking bedroom?
And I don't mean the girly ones.
I mean the fucking ones that are like the one who would loan,
who's a champion I the the,
the heavyweight champion or whatever.
Like I don't,
I don't know what her,
what her name is,
but that one I was just sitting there going,
all right,
what would she like in bed?
Okay,
that's going to go.
She is going to go one way or the other.
She is either exactly
what you think she is.
You know,
like the fucking Chicago bears are exactly what they were.
We,
she's easy to exactly what you think she's going to be.
Well,
she's going to be dominant and fucking holding you down slash scaring the shit
out of you.
Wondering if she's going to rip your Dick off or,
okay.
I,
I would actually bet.
I don't know.
Do you want the other way?
Yeah.
That she would actually be submissive.
She'd be so sick of beating the shit out of guys down in the octagon that she
would actually almost like one of those fucking,
uh,
Wall Street guys that's calling all the shots and then it just gets so fucking
sick of dominating the entire fucking planet that late at night goes to one of
those acid and m things and gets on a swing with one of those orange balls in
his mouth.
I don't fucking know,
but that's the shit I think of what I watched that show.
You should definitely watch the ultimate fighter.
Uh,
do they had this woman,
she looked like a fucking librarian or you know,
there's nerves she lost.
But I just thought it was fucking awesome.
Just looking at it going like,
look at that won't make,
you would have no clue.
You'd have no clue that,
you know,
if you talk some shit to her that she would just start raining elbows down on
you.
I just think it's fun.
I think it's amazing.
It's really fucking amazing.
Anyway,
so let's,
let's get on with the,
uh,
so I guess I ruined the podcast for this guy.
I got to read the last paragraph here.
He says,
uh,
also it might,
it might be a good idea to watch the movie and record your reactions.
I'll do it.
I can't sit through that shit.
Yeah.
Like it's too fucking lie.
He goes,
there's a scene where a wizard called
yeah,
rat aghast.
Okay.
Rat against the brown is being chased by Warburg's big wolves riding a sleigh
pulled by bunny rabbits.
Do this movie.
Like I would,
I would think that more like people who were into like hallucinogens would
actually watch this movie because that actually sounds fucking pretty amazing.
He says,
Gandalf goes,
you can't outrun these wars.
They are vermilion war.
The other wizard actually responds.
There are,
oh,
these are,
and then he says in parentheses,
some corny fantasy place rabbits.
I'd like to see them try.
Oh,
so he goes,
you can't outrun the the war.
These wars there.
Vermilion works.
And he said,
well,
these are Lilliputian rabbits.
I'd like to see them try.
That's actual fucking dialogue.
He goes,
and then they actually in on his face with a look of pseudo pseudo bad ass
determination.
You know what,
dude?
I think I'm going to watch that movie.
I think I'll eat up like a fucking pot cookie.
Maybe I'll watch it.
I don't want to do that though.
I don't want to put that on youtube and me fucking high giggling like a fucking
school girl watching some wizard on.
Oh,
fucking rabbit.
I don't want to do that publicly.
All right.
Carrie Underwood.
He said she's a singer,
right?
He said,
I recently listened to your podcast,
or is that one of those guys with a woman name?
You know,
like that Shamar guy would have the fuck his name is,
does the hair products and also acts in movies,
doesn't he?
I came,
it was a fucking name is he goes,
I recently listened to your podcast concerning the song before he cheats by
Carrie Underwood.
Very funny.
By the way.
Uh,
you might be interested to know how she has a new song.
She has a new song out that takes that theme to a completely new level in the
song to Black Cadillac's.
A woman discovers their husband is cheating on her.
Apparently the mistress didn't realize he was married because she and the wife
collaborate on murdering the guy.
MMM.
Not just destroying his truck and humiliating him in front of a new girl.
They end the guy's life.
Here are a few lines from the end of the song.
All right.
It says,
yeah,
they,
they took turns laying a rose down through a handful of dirt deep into the
ground.
He's not the only one who had a secret to hide.
So I'm thinking about writing my own country song.
The title might be something like cold dinner,
raw knuckles.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
that's one of those double standards that you understand why it exists.
You know,
it's not like women go around killing guys all the fucking time when we're
really comes to violence.
Guys do it more to women than the other way around.
And uh,
it's one of the things that makes it being a guy funny because if a woman
actually like right to the point of like cut and get your dick cut off by a
woman,
like it's just considered funny.
Like,
well dude,
she cut your dick off like other guys.
Just think it's hilarious.
We're not going to wear pink,
you know,
for all the guys who got their dicks fucking sliced off and thrown in the
garbage disposal.
Well not,
we're just going to laugh at you.
MMM.
What happened?
You know what?
I really hear that.
I really don't hear that as an anti man thing.
I hear somebody who's struggling to find a followup hit and is going back to the
wealth possibly one too many times,
but then again I listened to ACDC and they had like three or four themes that
they have been doing for 40 years and I think they sound better.
Better than ever,
right?
They sing about their balls,
the devil,
women in electricity and it's worked for them.
So good for her.
Good far.
Uh,
maybe next one will be like a,
the comes back like a Zombie and she has a relationship with a Zombie and then
he cheats on her
and then I don't know what she does,
however you kill a fucking Zombie and have to watch lord of the rings to figure
that one out.
Um,
advice on having a baby.
She had a baby marriage advice on having a baby.
Hey Bill,
I need some advice.
You're talking to me.
I what the fuck?
I'm nowhere near this.
He said,
my wife and I are both 27 years old.
She's a graduate from college and working.
I'm getting a master's degree and will not be done for another two and a half
years.
The issue is she is getting to the point where she wants to have a baby.
Not now but some,
but sometime right after I graduate I on the other hand and not wanting a baby
anytime soon,
but oh,
but by the time I graduate I will have been in college for nearly eight years
after I graduated.
My wife and I will have a dual income of well over a hundred grand a year.
I grew up in a family,
in a fairly poor family.
I worked hard to get my schooling so I want to enjoy the rewards.
I want a nice apartment,
nice things,
and to travel the world.
If we just started having kids,
we won't be able to travel and if we just have kids right after I graduate,
I'll go from a life of stress from school to a life of stress from parenthood.
By understand my wife's concern.
If we wait until we are 33 or 34 to start having kids,
we could have some trouble conceiving.
And if it takes us too long,
she could give birth to mentally challenged child,
which does run in my family,
Jesus Christ to this is one of the more serious ones.
I love my wife and plan on being with her the rest of my life.
It's just a shame that my goals are to travel and have nice things in her goals
are to start a family.
So what do you think,
Bill?
Any advice?
Uh,
that's some pretty heavy shit there.
Um,
well I don't understand why when you're,
you're,
um,
going to school right now that you guys can't save up a little bit of money and
go to Aruba for a few days.
You could do little mini ones you don't want,
I mean,
I think there's a way to kind of do both.
And um,
I think if you express all your concerns to your wife and just say,
look,
I don't want to be that couple that just goes from school to having kids.
And then once we have kids,
all we do is just do the kid thing.
Um,
I dunno dude,
I don't know what to tell you here.
Um,
fuck.
I definitely understand.
I mean,
you went from a life of poverty,
it's right to a life of school and then you're going to go right to a life of
being a parent.
When do you actually get to sit back and enjoy a nice flat screen TV,
watches some sports or maybe go travel in Europe or something like that.
Um,
look to it.
You could do this.
You could have a kid,
I don't know how close you are with,
you know,
the on either side.
Um,
I think you can have your cake and eat it.
Why don't you just have a fucking kid and then also save up for a fucking epic
10 day trip somewhere through,
um,
through Europe and then just,
just make a pact with your wife and just say,
listen,
once every two years or once every whatever,
I want to,
uh,
I want to go on a trip and we'll leave the kid behind or the kids behind.
My parents did that.
They went to Vegas and my grandparents parents came to time.
It was great.
We ended up developing a relationship with our grandparents.
It was a good thing and it was also good socially.
It was good for us as kids to have a different sort of disciplinary dynamic.
Jesus Christ.
I remember I tested my grandmother too when she broke a fucking wooden spoon
would have been over my head,
but I got my arm up and I blocked it.
I kept messing up.
I saw her the way we will rent in this.
We lived in a duplex when I was a kid for a certain,
a number of years in the way we had it set up was,
uh,
it went kitchen living room.
And then dining rooms.
He had to walk through the living room.
We kind of altered the living room and kitchen a couple of times trying to
figure out which was best.
And uh,
this was just a period where there was a,
it went kitchen and then we had the living room and then we're using the other
room was a dining room.
So anyways,
there was this old shitty rug and it was a hole in it.
So my mother had put up,
throw rug over the hole on the floor.
So I saw my grandmother walked by through the living room and she was setting
the table and she saw the,
uh,
the throw rug was messed up and I just heard her mumble to herself.
She said,
now why does this keep getting messed up?
So she walked into the kitchen,
that was literally my cue.
She'd straighten out,
walk to the kitchen.
So I said,
all right,
fine.
So I got off the couch and I messed it up and went over and I went back and I
sat down.
So then she comes walking out with the dishes or the food.
She sees it again.
She goes,
now what just happened?
It was Jack,
just straighten this out.
So she straightens it out.
It goes into the dining room,
walks back into the kitchen,
and then I got up and I messed it up again.
She came third time,
sees it again and she doesn't fucking say anything,
what should have been a warning to me.
So she straightened it out and then she walked into the kitchen and turned the
corner and I got back up again to go mess it up and right as I'm grabbing it to
mess it up,
I hear,
I hear this stomp and she took a quick step back and look back out and right in
the middle of it saw me messing it up and she just kept this wooden spoon in her
hand and just came fucking flying at me.
Like if it was an ax,
I wouldn't be here.
Right?
Was a hatchet.
I would have been dead.
She gave me like Billy Bob when she fucking,
when he kills that country singer,
right.
Came flying out.
And I just remember crouching down and put my arm up and it
did fucking snapped in half off on my forearm.
She had this look of anger on a face,
slammed it down,
snapped it over my arm,
and then she just,
after it snapchat,
she just went,
wow,
that's the end of that spoon.
And then she just walked back out into the kitchen and uh,
that was it.
So I think that's a good thing if they stay,
if they stay with their grandparents,
I think you can do both.
I think as a couple,
if you really sit down and you say,
what's important to you?
MMM.
You know,
and this is very easy for me to say,
not having a child and having it completely consume your life.
You who knows your priorities might change or whatever.
But there's also something to say too,
that if you start early,
I mean,
if you start it now,
you're 27 you kid would be 18 when you're 45 my age right now.
And then you can travel.
MMM.
You know,
45 kids out of college by the time you're 49,
then you have your golden years,
50,
60,
seventies,
eighties,
depending on how,
if you eat right,
you Joe's,
you can live right up to fucking 90 and you can go see the God damn world.
But there's no reason why you can't do that right now,
even though that you're in school.
There's no reason why he can't go to Puerto Rico or go to Hawaii.
There's some beautiful cities up in Canada.
You know,
Vancouver,
Toronto,
Montreal is fucking tremendous.
MMM.
There's all beautiful,
uh,
cities here in the states.
There's all kinds of things that you can do and you can do them really cheaply
when you don't have any kids to literally just backpack it.
Just put a backpack on,
staying fucking hostels.
Who gives a fuck?
You know,
just go.
I would just say,
go and do it.
I would just,
yeah,
do it now.
Do it now.
Uh,
but I think that you can do both.
And,
um,
I also say everybody I know who's ever had a kid has never regretted it.
Never,
never,
ever regretted it.
So,
um,
yeah,
you know,
I,
but I,
I think it's also important that if you do something like that to,
to,
to not lose yourself in all of it.
All right there.
I've said my peace.
All right.
Continuing on here.
Alcohol problem.
A bill.
Love the podcast watching a stand up right now on Netflix and has me crying
left.
Thank you.
Anyways,
I'm 25.
I'm a 25 year old male and I'm starting to come to terms with the fact I have an
alcohol.
Oh wait,
I forgot to do the other park.
Uh,
advertising here.
Hang on.
Sorry.
Ah,
fuck.
I always forget the other ones.
All right.
He voice a voice.
Everybody.
If you're an entrepreneur and a customer calls,
do you want the,
do you want it to seem like you're in a high rise window view,
fancy pants office or do you want them to know that you sit sitting there and
your underwears with he voice?
You can create the appearance of an entire building,
sales,
customer service,
tech support,
you name it.
It's going to seem like you're sitting in a high rise.
Give your customers the royal treatment with he voice.
He voice will for business calls to your home mobile or any number you choose.
Wherever you are,
he voice will find you.
You don't have time to take a call,
no big deal.
It's routed directly to your voicemail and you can read it at your convenience
as an email.
He voice not only gives you an edge over your competitors,
it takes away the edge of the big companies have over you right now and now you
can try it.
He voice for free for 30 days.
Go to [inaudible] dot com or just go to the podcastPage@billbird.com and click
on the voice banner and last but not least,
stamps.com everybody,
the post office version of Dollar Shave Club.
This makes your life easier.
When was the last time you heard of a post office being open?
24 seven huh?
Never.
They usually have limited hours.
Could be closed when you get there.
That's why you need stamps.com gets postage.
You can get postage when it's convenient for you.
You're in the driver's seat.
You can get a 24 seven right from your own desk.
stamps.com will save you time and the hassle of going to the post office.
No more driving,
finding parking,
standing in the lines,
all of that crap.
Just use your own computer and your printer to get official us postage for any
letter or package and the mail man picks it up.
Can't be any easier.
You'll save money with stamps.com to get exact postage,
the instant,
the instant you need it.
No more overpaying even get a special postage discounts that you can't get at
the post office.
I use Stan.
Stop.
Come to send out my posters,
my DVDs,
my tee shirts,
whatever crap I'm selling.
I've never had a problem and I'm a moron.
So if I can do it,
you can do it too.
So right now use my last name bur bur for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in [inaudible] that
stamps.com enter birth.
All Right,
alcohol problem.
Hey Bill,
I love the podcast.
I have a,
anyways,
I am 25 year old male and I'm starting to come to terms with the fact I have an
alcohol problem.
I drink six days a week and blackout at least once a week.
All right,
well the only saving grace you have is your 25,
so you might just be a little immature.
I don't know if you're an actual alcoholic,
but let me read the rest of this.
He says,
I drink six days a week blanket at least once a day.
The nights I get really drunk,
I really regret doing it and regret my actions.
Nothing serious,
just phone or text conversations I have with people I've considered going to Aa
but never have gone through with it.
Um,
I finally quit smoking two months ago and I'm worried if I tried to quit
drinking now I will start going crazy.
I know you have always mentioned you are stupid,
but I honestly agree with most of the advice you give up.
Well thank you.
He said,
my question is,
do you think I should try and quit cold Turkey or are there any other options I
can take?
One of my concerns with quitting completely is that most of my friends drink and
go out on weekends.
Um,
and I don't want to list risk losing all of my social life and seeing and seeing
me friends got all Irish.
Sarah's seeing me friends appreciate the advice.
Um,
all right dude,
all I can do is just tell you what has worked for me when I'm not drinking.
And
MMM,
the first two,
three days are brutal because all you've gone is two,
three days and there's definitely that feeling of,
well,
if I drink now,
I can start over again.
It's just trying to make up three days.
But if he can get through the first two,
three days,
once you get to the fourth day,
it's like,
all right,
I got a nice little streak going here.
Like I'm up to six days right now and I'm,
one of the hardest things to do is when you go out socially with people.
But I found that all you have to do,
all I have to do,
cause I don't know how dude,
if you're a full on alcoholic and you have the disease that might be harder for
you and you really should probably,
I would say talk to a recovered alcoholic.
But if you're like me,
all it takes is going out to the bar that first time when everybody's drinking
and you just order a,
I try to stay away from Soda and club Soda because then I mean that shit's not
good for either and I usually just order the cranberry juice and deal with the
departed.
Well what do you on your period jokes that everybody does?
I usually just go,
I don't even do cranberry and soda.
I just to cranberry juice straight up with lime and I just sorta nurse that
and then um,
I just kind of drink waters and you're actually,
you're fine.
You just got to do that that one night and then you've kind of set up a new
social experience that you're comfortable with and you can still go out and I
got to tell you,
yeah,
you get a distinct advantage when you're sober and everybody else's basically
getting fucked up because they're kind of,
first of all,
it's,
it's really entertaining to watch people just sort of roof roofie themselves and
you get through watching their behavior.
You get to see all the dumb things that you've done.
Um,
so you get to,
um,
without judging your friends,
you just sort of get to be like,
wow,
I was doing that.
Especially with alcohol.
I always say judgments the first thing to go.
And,
um,
I dunno.
I think you also have a better chance of meeting,
um,
a really nice woman if you're the sober one,
cause you're going to come off as responsible.
And also if your friends are also hitting on her and they're all sloppy drunk,
you're going to look even better yourself.
So I would,
you know,
if you,
if you're not feeling Aa,
which I understand,
if you just try you,
you what it is.
I don't know.
I have to replace the activity.
Like this week I decided,
you know,
that I was going to stop drinking.
So then what I did was I dove into playing drums and I'm doing that,
that Mike Johnston 10 days to faster hands workout.
So I just sort of replace,
you know,
like at night I just sorta like,
okay,
I'll go downstairs and I'll work,
I'll do the practice pad thing.
And uh,
you know,
I started working out.
He just,
you know what it is,
dude,
I feel you gotta replace the time that you're drinking and doing dumb shit with
shit that's also fun.
But you're sober doing it.
Because for me,
it's like if I just don't drink and I'm just sitting around doing nothing,
that's gonna make me want to drink because it's just like,
well,
I usually go out and drink and have fun right now,
but if I'm actually doing something else,
um,
like went out and I saw a movie last night,
he just,
you fill up the time to learn how to cook.
There's all kinds of key learnings.
Fucking second language.
There's all kinds of things do that.
Like,
you know,
basically you're in your twenties right now and uh,
you're trying to appeal to the opposite sex here.
So you know,
if you can add some shitty a game,
you're going to move up in the draft.
You're going to get a better woman here.
If you're fucking bilingual.
What woman doesn't like that is sober and responsible.
She's going to like that.
Who knows?
You learn to play a couple of songs on a Flamenco Guitar,
take around on a fucking row boat.
You're in there,
bunch of grit.
Nothing bad comes from becoming sober other than your,
you are bored shitless but you,
you've head gets smaller because you drop all that booze way.
I'm telling you,
you,
you won't regret it.
You definitely won't regret it.
Um,
but like I said,
if he got the disease and that thing,
you might,
you're going to need more professional help.
And I would actually seek out a fellow alcoholic.
Um,
and then I would use AA and all of that shit.
You,
Eh,
you know,
I dunno.
I'm just a control freak and I don't like people telling me what to do.
So I would have to use it in a way that worked for me.
You know,
I'm not going to be standing down there smoking cigarettes,
eating donuts,
you know,
talking to those people with their yellow fingers and shit.
Like I,
I couldn't do it that way.
I got buddies of mine,
they go every once in a while to go to a meeting,
you know,
like the way I go to church every once in a while with fucking once a year
they'll do a boy,
whatever works for you.
But I'm not,
nothing bad ever comes from a cleaning up your act.
So,
uh,
I hope that helps you.
All right.
Okay.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
Um,
I'm off the road again this week.
I'm,
I'm definitely going to be around.
I'm working.
I might have a surprise show out here in la where I'm actually going to be,
you know,
working on my act possibly next week.
I think there's rumors that I might be doing a full hour at a local comedy club
and um,
cause I gotta make sure I'm on my game when I do a DC,
New York and Upper Darby a that's it.
That's a podcast.
Everybody,
I hope you enjoyed it.
Uh,
he was the wrap up now that the show's over,
don't forget again to sign up for your free trial of Hulu plus a Hulu plus lets
you binge on thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV,
PC,
smart phone or tablet.
Uh,
it's the future.
That's the way to watch TV in the future right now.
Okay.
Support this podcast podcast podcast and get an extended free trial of Hulu.
Plus when you go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com and click the Hulu
plus banner or go to Hulu plus.com/bill.
That's Hulu plus.com/bill.
That is the podcast for this week.
Once again,
I'll be down lago on La Cienega just north of Beverly Boulevard and a are going
to be doing this great benefit.
I love doing benefits cause I'm a piece of shit.
God knows I need to work on my Karma.
Lord knows that.
So I get to go down and help a wonderful cause that helps out,
uh,
you know,
come on.
It helps out.
Pitbulls what's better than a dog is now,
right?
Cleo,
come over here.
Come here.
Cleo.
She Sleeping Cleo.
Hey,
no,
she's out like a light.
Um,
I'm boring her with my podcasts.
All right,
that's it.
All right everybody go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week and a,
if you haven't watched the world series yet,
uh,
it's a dandy.
Two Games.
That piece.
One more game in St Louis.
Oh,
you know what I didn't talk about.
I know that the,
the world series has always been to three too.
I always feel like I always just feel like the three in the middle.
What would you rather have if you were managing the team?
Would you rather,
I just feel like the advantage goes to the team with the lesser record with
those three in the middle,
even though overall four to seven games you're going to be on the road.
I just feel like the way it's broken up,
you just sort of spend a weekend in Boston and then you host a home stand,
right?
You got three straight games.
We could sleep in your own bed,
eat your own food,
fucking chill out.
And then if need be,
you go back and you're getting how you deal with another weekend.
They,
they break it up nicely.
Um,
and I feel like the two,
three,
two,
it just gives the team with the lesser record home field advantage.
So the first five games that makes games one and two a must win for the team
with the better record.
But,
uh,
I dunno.
Maybe that's just me.
My anxiety is a fan and maybe professional athletes could,
they don't give a shit.
But I've always found that weird.
Like I,
I liked when the NBA used to do two,
two,
one,
one.
Um,
it seemed fair,
but I think the athletes didn't like to travel.
You know,
they got to lug all that TV equipment.
I don't know.
They just,
that's just one to think about.
All right,
so that's the deal.
Everybody,
that's the podcast far for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.
Goodbye.